ça quand vous entendez alliera b le
maire de trappes qui dit que tu rappes
est une ville voilà comme les autres où
il se passe aussi bien des bonnes choses
que des mauvaises et que c'est une ville
voilà qu'est ou voilà il faut essayer de
faire la dette découvert plein de gens
voilà qui font aujourd'hui le bonheur de
la france qu'est ce que vous dites à ça
ben moi je trouve que le maire de
trappes est très talentueux il est très
talentueux dans ce n'est pas ce qu'il va
dire une saloperie derrière parce que il
a une façon très élégante et très
diplomatique de nier la réalité c'est
quoi la réalité c'est qu'en réalité tout
le monde sait à trappes mangeant plus le
connaîtra parce qu'il se trouve que le
lycée où on saigne didier le maire j
enseigne et moi-même en l'an 2000 donc
ce projet seur j'ai fait un remplacement
en fait soeur kelly qu'il avait été
menacé voilà exactement donc je dire
tous les français savent qu'il y a en
france trappe n'y fait pas exception il
y a en france effectivement des zones
non pas de non droit mais des zones de
non france et trappes en fait partie
alors moi au début de ce le maire j'ai
eu j'ai eu envie de de croire en votre
bonne foi mais quand j'ai vu votre votre
parcours politique vous êtes de gauche
vous avez appartenu au ps et ensuite
vous avez suivi la gauche kémaliste de
benoît hamon
vous dites que vous défendez la
république française très bien mais le
problème c'est que le courant politique
auquel vous appartenez a tout fait
depuis 40 ans pour que la république ne
soit plus française en réalité trappe
comme beaucoup d'autres villes en france
est devenue une médina
voilà là comment voulez-vous 40 ans
comment voulez vous comment voulez vous
qu'une médina soit française
comment voulez vous que dans une ville
où on parle l'arabe
on s'habille à l'arabe on vit à l'arabe
ont pris en arabe
comment voulez vous qu'on se sente
français faire leur placement d'une
semaine j'ai vu tout danger par une
semaine six mois si vous voulez moi je
voilà donc la deuxième chose que je vais
vous dire c'est que vous nous dites
également que voulu te faire depuis que
vous êtes élu maire que vous avez un
gros effort de lutte contre les
phénomènes de radicalisation contre le
communautarisme déjà donc déjà au point
de vue oui mais donc déjà voulez vous
reconnaissez qu'il y assez qui s'est
cassé phénomène attrape pas ce qu'on va
vous entendre trappe serait une ville
mais ce que je constate un parent c'est
que vous déployer une énergie dévorante
depuis plusieurs jours pour déglinguer
le témoignage de didier lemaire alors
que je vous ai jamais vus sur aucun
plateau venir nous fait et nous faire
état de des services que vous avez rendu
dans la lutte contre l'islamisation de
la ville contre la communautarisation
etc
voilà je pense que le but en réalité
c'est que il n'y ait pas de trappe qui
se généralise sur le territoire français
voyez donc déjà il faut commencer par
admettre le réel ouvrir les yeux sur le
réel vous pouvez pas casser le
thermomètre
alors que le patient souffre d'un cancer
en stade iv et qui provoque de la fièvre
vous pouvez pas dire je balance le
thermomètre des témoignages et hop
donc la meilleure que la réalité
n'existe plus qu'est ce que vous
répondez à la jambe et siens c'est
exactement la raison pour laquelle j'ai
accepté votre invitation serait bien
badauds sais pas grand pièce où vous
n'êtes pas des brèches ces caricatures
attrape ont pris en arabe à l'église
catholique de trappes où se réunissent
des centaines de personnes tous les
dimanches matins on doit prier aussi en
arabe pendant que vous y êtes quelle est
la proportion de cas de mutation
chrétien le jeu ne découpe pas dans la
population ouïghoure y moi je suis
français est républicain est d'accord
les gens en face de moi et son français
qu'ils soient de pondichéry de bretagne
qu'ils soient catholiques ou musulmans
et je fais pas de statisme et qu'est ce
que c'est bon séjour de s'arrêter demain
theron moi je vous aime et celle de vos
élucubrations josé pas interrompu ce que
valait le droit d exprimer en démocratie
donc pour mercy ici dans ma ville
on vit vraiment de façon paisible et
apaisée il ya des difficultés qu'on
combat tous les jours